[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire se reçoit aujourd'hui
christophe bourseiller pour sa nouvelle
histoire de l'ultra-gauche aux éditions
du surf
d'où viennent les black blocks les
stadistes les nouveaux autonome c'est
toute une histoire qui remonte au début
du siècle dernier qu'il va nous raconter
jeu recevra ensuite nathalie quintane
pour un hamster à l'école qui vient de
paraître à la fabrique
normalement je lave ou je ne lis pas les
livres de profs qu'il y en a chaque
année qui nous expliquent que leurs
élèves sont des tueurs en puissance et
qu'il faut rétablir d'urgence l'autorité
en les enfermant dans des camps de
travail
amstar à l'école c'est autre chose c'est
une écrivain qu'il a écrit 25 ans
qu'elle publie net à lesquin thann et
celui ci est un des livres les plus
drôles que j'ai lu depuis longtemps et
aussi parfois l'un des plus tristes il
faut bien le dire mais commençons tout
de suite par notre époque qu'est ce qui
la caractérise
en ce début de xxième siècle nos invités
répondent en images voici celle de
nathalie quintane alors de quoi
s'agit-il
ce sont les célébrités de juste milieu
des parlementaires de la monarchie de
juillet et quand je les ai vus alors là
je suis pas sûr que ce soit oui c'est
ceux qui sont en large il en terre cuite
mais je les ai vus en bronze aux
beaux-arts de marseille au musée des
beaux-arts et je me suis dit que c'était
difficile de ne pas penser à certains de
nos députés
voilà donc je te j'ai trouvé que c'était
on s'amuse à essayer de retrouver
certains de nos députés dans ses figures
là qui date d'il ya 150 ans quoi c'est
le très drôle c'est honoré daumier oui
c'était domicile et ce sont les
caricatures de l'époque mais à une
époque où quand on caricature et on
risquait la prison il faut bien savoir
c'est pas comme aujourd'hui tout à fait
ouais ouais ça ça reste très puissant et
on envoie un tout petit peu mais il ya
toute une galerie et on a vraiment il a
travaillé sur sur le suppose la totalité
de l'époque ou en tout cas il y en a
beaucoup trop et donc il est modelée
ensuite il s'en servait pour faire ces
caricatures en dessin voilà les les
célébrités du juste milieu
votre image avoue christophe bourseiller
pourquoi est elle attirer votre
attention
alors écoutez
vous voyez j'ai été un peu lorsqu'il ya
eu ce n était pas les romains qui ont
pris le capitole c'est elle et les pros
trump donc lorsqu'il ya eu récemment la
prise du capitole j'ai été frappé par le
style des manifestants ou des activistes
et voyez ce personnage m'a beaucoup
fasciné ce personnage au visage peint
mélange de cowboy d'indiens de trappeurs
et de beatniks qui résume peut-être le
21ème siècle pour moi c'est à dire un
siècle où droite et gauche ne sais plus
mais où il ya une espèce de colère
terrible et on est dans un monde marqué
par des mouvements de colère et pour moi
ce trappeur mystérieux me ressemble un
peu à un gilet jaune il ressemble à tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui veulent eux veulent
tout détruire et j'ai l'impression que
ce qu'on vit actuellement c'est une
sorte d' extrémisation de la société
avec comme ça la colère qui devient
omniprésente
c'est pour ça que cette photo m'a
intéressé m'a interpellé comme on dit
comme on dit maintenant
hélas et bien commençons
[Musique]
christophe bourseiller vous publiez donc
nouvelle histoire de l'ultra-gauche aux
éditions du surf
alors commençons par aujourd'hui c'est
quoi l'ultra gauche aujourd'hui c'est
pas la france a subi c'est pas le npa le
pc encore moins ce ne sont pas les
marxistes léninistes ni les trotskistes
ni les maoïstes ni les anarchistes ni
les indigéniste alors c'est quoi
l'ultra gauche aujourd'hui est tout à
fait compris l ultra gauche n'est
surtout pas l'extrême gauche
alors pour bien comprendre ça il suffit
de simplement de comprendre que
l'extrême gauche en fait c'est une
étiquette qui recouvre un ensemble de
courants que vous et que vous venez
d'énumérer
en fait ces courants se divise en deux
grands blocs vous avez un bloc on
pourrait dire autoritaire et léniniste
avec tous les léninistes les les les
trotskistes les maoïstes et staliniens
dont vous avez parlé
et puis vous avez un bloc anti
autoritaire dans lequel il ya deux
familles historiques
l'une est très ancienne elle remonte au
19e siècle ce sont les anarchistes et
l'autre qui date quand même du début du
xxème siècle où gallas en temps c'est
l'ultra gauche ultra gauche et à courant
historiquement un courant marxiste anti
autoritaire et aujourd'hui alors on les
reconnaît on les voit dans les black
blocks on a beaucoup beaucoup vu les
black blocks en france ça date de des
manifs contre le le contrat première
embauche de dominique de villepin steurs
2006 mais surtout les avait explosé à
partir de du 1er mai 2010huit là tout à
coup on a découvert les black blocks
dans paris et puis avec les gilet jaune
alors c'est black blocks c'est pas un
groupe dit vous ce qu'une méthode
oui c'est une méthode c'est à dire que
nous sommes avec les lélés ce qu'on
appelle entre guillemets les black
blocks nous sommes dans l'héritage d'une
histoire très lointaine et même d'une
histoire activistes très lointaine qui
va jusqu'en mai 68 avec les enragés de
nanterre et puis ensuite il ya eu un
événement fondateur qui était en 1971 le
pillage du quartier latin par des des
militants ultra gauche puis qui ensuite
se sont fait appeler à parfait 1975 les
autonome que la police allemande a
désigné comme blague
à partir de 1982 et qui arrive là
aujourd'hui ce sont des gens qui sont
des anti autoritaire des gens qui sont
dans une violence radicale vis à vis de
ce monde c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont
absolument pas dans une violence de
stratégie mais dans une violence
véritablement presque symbolique qui
consiste à frapper réellement les
symboles du vieux monde
d'une certaine façon pourrait-on dire
est il effectivement il refuse une
organisation militante classique donc
il refuse les étiquettes et donc en fait
ils interviennent sur la forme de
collectif de petits collectifs qui se
fédèrent parfois qui se regroupent et
puis qui se désassembler qui discutent
entre eux ils sont pas toujours d'accord
entre eux s'est même rare évidemment
qu'ils soient d'accord entre eux mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
cesser ces activistes violents en
réalité d'abord il faut voir que c'est
une violence assez complexe parce qu'en
fait il ne casse pas tout c'est à dire
que les autonomes qui se constitue en
bloc noir en black blocks en cortège de
tête devant les manifestations c'est
autonome par exemple vont casser la
banque de france ne vont pas casser le
petit épicier du coin où le petit
libraire parce qu'on veuille en fait
pour eux la banque de france c'est le
symbole du capitalisme
je me souviens de lors d'une des dunes
des épisodes de décembre 2020 lorsqu'il
a eu les manifestations contre la loi de
sécurité globale à paris ils ont essayé
de prendre d'assaut les palissades qui
protège et vous savez là la colonne de
la bastille pourquoi pour reprendre la
bastille
donc on est encore une fois dans une
violence symbolique et là où le projet
politique peut sembler évidemment un peu
utopique c'est que l'idée en quelque
sorte c'est de montrer l'exemple aux
peuples à dire de d'exercer une violence
révolutionnaire pour que les prolétaires
à leur tour s'empare des pavés et que
les prometteurs à leur tour détruisent
tout et si possible que les prolétaires
près de l'elysée pour ensuite instauré
le communisme de façon spontanée en
dehors de tout parti le communisme qui
serait l'assemblée internationale des
conseils d'ouvriers un conseil des
ouvriers tentent une assemblée générale
de travailleurs élus est révolue et
révocable à tout moment
vous voyez c'est une évidemment quelque
chose d'un
peut-être utopique mais en même temps
c'est un courant moi je trouve assez
fascinant et j'ai voulu montrer à quel
point ce courant ils passent pour des
pour des imbéciles des black blocs quand
on voit des gens qui viennent tout
casser on les montre à la télé on a
l'impression que c'est plutôt des gens
qui viennent s'amuser en détruisant en
fait ils sont pour beaucoup d'entre eux
les héritiers d'un d'une descendance
passionnante avec un apport culturel
considérable et donc sort évidemment
ordos et leur violence ou sur la
soutenir
j'ai trouvé intéressant de mettre en
avant cet héritage alors on a bien
compris à les black blocks sont qu'on
appelle souvent les casseurs s'ils
viennent dans les manifestations c'est
comme vous l'avez dit c'est au fond
c'est pour donner l'exemple
c'est pour que les autres se mettent eux
aussi à casser mais pas n'importe quoi
des symboles des symboles importants à
leurs yeux de l'état ou du capitalisme
ils veulent exercer une violence réelle
là ou là où les autres se contenteraient
bien d'une violence symbolique en fait
c'est ce qui pourrait caractériser
l'ultra-gauche balais lors agenda est
complètement différent de celui de la
gauche traditionnelle
la gauche traditionnelle va manifester
pour les retraites elle va manifester
contre la loi de sécurité globale tous
ces slogans eux ça ne les intéresse pas
eu ce qu'ils veulent c'est attaquer
frontalement le capitalisme alors
évidemment quand ils font ça va le
laisser collatéral qu'on peut critiquer
c'est qu'ils vont décrédibiliser la
manifestation à laquelle ils se sont
adjoints par exemple si vous prenez les
manifestations récentes contre la loi de
sécurité globale sont des manifestations
qui disent faut pas que la police ait
trop de pouvoirs attention on va vers un
état policier
là dessus qu'est ce qu'on voit à la télé
on voit des casseurs qui s'en prennent
aux policiers qui casse tout et donc que
disent les gens chez eux
ah bah oui finalement il doit de
sécurité globale ça serait peut-être pas
si mal donc c'est totalement contre
productif pour les manifestants donc il
est certain que l'agenda des black
blocks d'un agenda qui est complètement
en dehors de la politique traditionnelle
et d'ailleurs je sais même pas si on
peut considérer l'ultra gauche comme une
branche de la gauche soit l'ultra gauche
c'est aujourd'hui un courant qui est en
dehors qui est un courant
révolutionnaire
radical et guy debord lui même qui est
l'un des grands penseurs historique de
ce courant se situait bien au delà de la
droite et de la gauche
et c'est vrai pour les black blocks de
manifester contre la nouvelle loi de
sécurité globale n'a pas de sens puisque
pour eux on est déjà dans la sécurité
globale depuis très très longtemps et
que c'est pas une petite loi de plus qui
va y changer quoi que ce soit dans les
aides
est ce que est ce que c'est aussi
l'ultra gauche est ce que sont les
lampes et combien sont ils
alors il ya plusieurs questions d'abord
combien sont ils
en gros il ya il existe aujourd'hui en
france une gauche libertaire d'environ
3000 personnes
on pourrait dire est super c'est 3000
personnes ne sont pas tous violents
ce sont des gens qui sont sur des
positions anti autoritaire qui refuse
l'état qui refuse ce monde mais on
pourra dire que les violences et entre
700 et 1000 personnes qui sont des gens
qui vont d'un front de lutte à l'autre
c'est à dire que vous allez retrouver
dans les rues en bordure des
manifestations si vous avez la retrouver
à calais pour défendre les sans papiers
ou les migrants vous allez retrouver
dans les acp d'effectivement parce que
une douleur peut être réussite politique
du du 20e du 21e siècle c'est le fait
d'avoir donné vie à ce phénomène
politique territoriale c'est trop
conquête territoriale qu'est la zad la
zad c'est véritablement une création
idéologique de l'aide de l'ultra gauche
pourquoi parce que dans les années 1990
un théoricien ultra gauche qui se
faisait appeler hakim bey avait publié
un livre qui s'appelait taz dans lequel
il expliquait qu'il fallait se
constituer en zone d'autonomie
temporaire
un peu comme on a vu à portland par
exemple en 2020 lors des manifestations
blacklight matters par exemple créé et
développé deux territoires libérés et ça
a donné l'idée à certains ultra gauche
qui était parti du côté de la ruralité
pour des raisons écologiste radicale
entre autres et bien de constituer des
zones d'autonomie durable des zones
d'autonomie défensive des zones à
défendre enfin ce sont les multiples
l'acronyme de zad et donc les adh c'est
vraiment une création de l'ultra gauche
à laquelle se sont adjointes ensuite
d'autres courants l'alleud
l'ultra gauche le ried s est jamais de
prendre la direction c'est plutôt l'idée
de donner l'exemple de susciter des
vocations et ensuite de laisser les
autres reprendre le flambeau en quelque
sorte
alors on l'a compris votre livre c'est
un peu la généalogie de cet ultra gauche
là j'ai commencé par la fin aujourd'hui
mais on va remonter dans le temps voir
d'où cela vient
au fond c'est c'est l'histoire d'un
autre communisme qui serait né en marge
de deux du bolchévisme et delahaye de la
révolution d'octobre un les l'ultra
gauche alors on peut le on pourrait la
faire remonter la révolution française
mais mais là on va se contenter de du
20e siècle
qu'est ce qui différencie dès le début
l'ultra gauche du communisme qui à
l'époque qui est un extrémisme 1 il faut
bien imaginer comme les bolcheviks en
au départ ils sont tous ultra gauche
pour étourdir tueur mais quand lénine
prend le pouvoir en 1917 quand la
révolution russe éclats il ya un certain
nombre de partisans de la révolution
russe notamment les allemands autour de
rosa luxembourg et karl i ppte net chez
quelques autres à gauche germano
irlandaise comme on l'appelle qui vont
dire à lénine lénine tu en train de
tromper parce que ta vision du marxisme
c'est que le parti communiste doit
diriger le prolétariat et que le parti
communiste doit prendre le pouvoir
or distillats lénine tuyaux lieu de
donner le pouvoir au prolétariat tu est
en train d'instaurer la dictature du
parti sur le prolétariat donc le rêve
communiste avec toi lénine est en train
de devenir une dictature alors faut dire
qu'ils avaient raison là il ne se
trompait pas du tout à partir de là ces
groupes qui au départ était pro pro
bolchévique pro pro russe si vous voulez
pro soviétiques vont évoluer vers
d'abord une critique du léninisme
ensuite une critique du bolchévisme
ensuite pour certains une critique du
marxisme et pour certains une critique
de la politique elle même c'est à dire
que ce sont des laboratoires d'idées
absolument passionnant et et on va voir
a couché des idées des des concepts
formidables qui sont à coucher dans ces
petits laboratoires d'idées maintenant
ce qui est formidable c'est que le
communisme officiel si on si on par
exemple si
on s'en tient aux chiffres sont peut
être discutable du livre noir du
communisme de stéphane courtois
ça va autour de 81 2 millions de morts
alors que l'ultra gauche sept autres
communistes il ya deux trois morts c'est
bien le maximum tout autant que deux
pour cent ans d'existence
on est là face à des tout petits
cénacles qui sont principalement des
cénacles de théoriciens qui
réfléchissent et qui tente de repenser
leur engagement dans une perspective qui
est intéressante parce que c'est une
perspective moderniste c'est à dire et
10 mais finalement il faut adapter notre
engagement révolutionnaire à l'époque
présente au monde moderne
ce qui amène par exemple guy debord et
raul l'année games à réfléchir à se dire
mais pourquoi cette société prétendument
démocratique dans laquelle on vit la
société moderne de la fin du xxème
siècle pourquoi est elle aussi
coercitives et donc réfléchir sur les
rouages de cette société les
situationnistes vont mettre en lumière
les rouages de la société moderne et
c'est tout un travail qui est absolument
fascinant
donc si vous voulez il ya là un héritage
théorique prodigieux mais un héritage
qu'on peut que certains n'hésitent pas à
faire remonter à spartacus la figure de
spartacus semblent être une
une figure un peu indiscuté est
indiscutable de l'ultra gauche
spartacus et les salades qui se
rebellent contre l' empire romain oui
c'est ça spartacus c'est la révolte des
esclaves et tout au long de l'histoire
du mouvement révolutionnaire et bien
vous allez voir des militants reprendre
à leur compte cette image de spartacus a
commencé par rosa luxembourg
lorsque en 1919 elle lance la révolution
spartakiste en allemagne une
insurrection énorme
il va y avoir un moment très court
d'ailleurs dans l'histoire c'est la
seule fois où l'ultra gauche va devenir
un mouvement de masse grâce à cette
insurrection spartakiste et on va même
voir apparaître pendant quelques années
un parti communiste des ouvriers
d'allemagne le cas à rien à voir
avec le kpd prosoviétique bien sûr qui
lui va incarner phénomène unique dans
l'histoire un mouvement ultra gauche de
masse enfin le reste du temps la plupart
du temps les ultra gauche sont des
théoriciens marxistes
enfin tout change quand même
à partir des années 1960 parce que là
n'est pas trop vite christophe où on va
on va y arriver mais d'abord yahia le
moment où lénine réagi en 1920 lénine
publie le gauchisme maladies infantiles
du communisme
jeudi le titre qu'on a retenu ses pales
titre exact d'ailleurs communisme le
gauchiste en 1920 et c'est là et alors
là évidemment c'est assez drôle parce
que c'est dans la bouche de lénine et de
façon injurieuse qu'apparaît le terme
ultra gauche
en fait c'est lénine qui inventent
l'ultra gauche en 1920 dans la maladie
infantile du communisme le gauchisme et
je me souviens lorsque michèle alliot
marie était crédité par les journalistes
d'avoir inventé le terme ultra gauche en
bah ça me faisait un peu sourire parce
que c'est lénine quand bape qui est le
véritable créateur de cette expression
mais finalement c'est intéressant parce
que les groupes dont nous parlons les
collectifs dont nous parlons refuse
toute étiquette donc au fond ultra
gauche mais c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
dans le livre que j'ai publié vous aimez
beaucoup de sous titres ou alors il ya
communiste libertaire communiste de
conseils de gauche communistes
situationniste qu'on saisisse enfin en
bref c'est sûr des sobriquets qu'on leur
accole mai mais eux l'important c'est
d'inventer de frayer cette espèce
d'inventer cette autre communisme en
fait alors pendant qu'on les voit tout
au long des années
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit ils sont
très peu nombreux
il pas certain qu'ils aient une
influence considérable 10 secondes sur
la seconde guerre mondiale ni même sur
la décolonisation c'est vraiment à
partir des années 60 que ça fourmille
d'abord avec la revue socialisme ou
barbarie
c'est la revue de cornelius castoriadis
on voit bien que l'ultra gauche
en france c'est un truc d'intello au
départ on le verra ensuite avec
l'internationale situationniste de guy
debord
là aussi ce sont des intellos ben c'est
à dire que si on voulait encore plus
cruel il faudrait dire ce ne sont
surtout pas des prolétaires
ce sont tous des jeunes gens d'origine
bourgeoise voire parfois extrêmement
fortunés comme guy debord qui était
quelqu'un de qui avait deux un grand
capital si je puis dire également amadeo
bord dix gars qui était issue d'une des
plus vieilles familles aristocratiques
italienne donc ce sont des gens
évidemment qu'ils ne sont pas dus du
milieu prolétarien mais c'est vrai qu'on
leur doit des avancées très importantes
et je pense par exemple le voyez vous
citiez la revue socialisme ou barbarie
alors cornelius castoriadis c'est quand
même le penseur du totalitarisme c'est à
dire que c'est vraiment lui qui va
terroriser toute une critique du
totalitarisme
à une époque où la gauche dans son
ensemble et bébé d'admiration devant
l'union soviétique cuba la chine rouge
l'albanie stalinienne le vietnam et le
cambodge des khmers mouche
donc c'est vrai que quand ils eussent
castoriadis lui va être d'une lucidité
absolument extraordinaire et claude
lefort qui est le deuxième grand penseur
de socialisme ou barbarie lui on lui
doit une réflexion de fond sur la nature
des régimes démocratiques
il ya là quelque chose de très important
après il ya un autre penseur qui va
jouer un rôle aussi très important moins
connu c'est anton pannecoucke qui est un
pont ce rôle landais qui va lui
véritablement théorisé une
inventé on pourrait dire une théorie
révolutionnaire adapté au monde moderne
dépassant le marxisme donc il ya cet
aspect là ensuite guy debord et raul van
heghe mdd bull est ce qui caractérise
guy debord et raul van heyghen c'est le
fait de mettre en lumière les rouages de
la société contemporaine en dix ans
grosso modo nous sommes dans une société
du spectacle
alors qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire par
là ce qu'ils veulent dire par là c'est
qu'au fond nous sommes tous en quelque
sorte les acteurs d'un film dont on n'a
pas écrit le scénario
c'est à dire que nous nous croyons
maîtres de nos vies mais en réalité
c'est le contexte le théories
historiques c'est ce sont deux origines
c'est notre milieu social s'est enfin
bref notre famille qui nous
conditionnent et donc guy debord et
banner game en disant il faut vivre sans
temps mort et jouir sans entraves à
l'époque appel au fonds à redevenir
maître de sa vie
evans et game à une très bonne formule
dans son livre traité de savoir vivre à
l'usagé des jeunes générations il dit
nous devons devenir des maîtres sans
esclaves
voilà il ya vraiment cette idée de
reconquête de sa vie quotidienne qui est
fondamentale et qui va influencer
énormément de sociologues et chercheurs
comme par exemple le jean baudrillard
entre autres mais beaucoup d'autres
jacques ellul
ce sont des dépenses heures protestants
des dépenses heures de toutes sortes
qu'ils vont vraiment lire de bord avec
passion et qui vont nourrir leur
réflexion sur les rouages de la société
alors luttera l'ultra gauche évidemment
se manifestent violemment on peut le
dire en 1968 en mai 68 avec ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque les enragés de
nanterre on va aller voir au moment de
l'occupation delà de la sorbonne il ya
des slogans qui fleurissent à la
sorbonne qui vont sonder des slogans
typique de l'ultra gauche
elles sont là et et tous alors on a
l'impression que ça s'arrête après après
mai 68 il pas du tout en fait c'est le
début du mouvement autonome
les autonomes ça va être très important
on les voit arriver en italie en espagne
en france jean marc rouillan d'action
directe que j'ai reçus dans cette
émission disait qu'on ne l'avait oublié
mais à quel point les années 70 ont été
violentes en france même si on n'a pas
connu
le terrorisme qu'ont connu les italiens
les allemands qu'on connaîtra de façon
tout à fait minime en comparaison avec
action directe ya une cagnotte violent
tassement là c'est le fait souvent des
autonomes donc de l'ultra gauche
oui oui la période qui va de 1970 à 1979
on pourrait dire inclut 1
c'est une période marquée par vraiment
mais de un nombre incroyable d'attentats
quand aujourd'hui par exemple le rendu
n'est dit oui attention il ya une montée
de la violence ultra gauche qui l'a dit
récemment à c'est sans commune mesure
avec ce qui se passait dans les années
1970 mais pour bien comprendre
historiquement d'où vient cette violence
autonome
il faut juste comprendre une chose c'est
que les ultra gauche sont des
théoriciens mais à partir des années
1960 il ya un certain nombre d'
anarchiste ont commencé à se poser des
questions sur leur héritage anarchistes
et qui vont rallier le courant
communiste libertaire et là il ya un
monsieur qui va avoir une très grosse
influence qui s'appelle daniel guérin et
daniel guérin va dire au fond il ya plus
il n'ya plus vraiment de différence
entre les marxistes et les anarchistes
la vraie différence elle est entre les
anti autoritaire et les autoritaires et
il va écrire un livre qui va avoir
beaucoup d'influencé qui va s'appeler
pour un marxisme libertaire mais alors
tous ces anarchistes qui vont finalement
aller sur des positions qui sont les
mêmes que les ultra gauche sont des
activistes et en fait les anarchistes
pour devenir à partir des années 1960 un
peu le bras armé des théoriciens de
l'ultra gauche
et c'est à partir de cette irruption des
communistes libertaires dans le
mouvement social que on va voir arriver
les premières violences le pillage du
quartier latin en 1971 et puis ensuite
dans toutes les manifestations
apparition d'un alors on les appelle les
casseurs les provocateurs puis à partir
de 1975 lorsque en italie des maoïstes
des anarchistes finalement tombent
d'accord pour donner chair aux termes
d'autonomie
l'idée c'est de dépasser des mouvements
institué en disant ce qui compte c'est
les pratiques révolutionnaires plus que
la théorie ça va tout à fait dans le
sens de ce que disaient les ultra gauche
à ce moment là bas les casseurs qui sont
donc des gens issus
pour beaucoup d'entre eux de ce marxisme
libertaire les casseurs vont se
transformant en autonome et on va parler
des autonomes et ce serpent de mer des
autonomes c'est extraordinaire parce que
avec des hauts et des bas il est
toujours là en 2021 voyez ça ne les
changent pas alors moi je vois des
politologues nous dit par exemple je
rapporte d'une politique c'était
extraordinaire nous dira alors le
cortège de tête vous savez le cortège de
tête c'est les autonomes qui vont se
mettre devant la manifestation pour
faire une sorte de manif sauvage qui va
s'en prendre à la police et aux vitrines
etc
elle disait le cortège de tête existe
depuis 2016
alors moi je veux bien mais non non le
cortège de tête il existe depuis 1971
je comprenais staff les domaines
extrêmement sien c'est s'adresse elle
n'a vraiment rien de nouveau mais c'est
je ne comprends pas qu'il ya un tel
manque de mémoire
parmi les journalistes ou même les
chercheurs et c'est surtout pour ça que
j'ai voulu écrire la nouvelle histoire
de l'ultra gauche pour la libye qu'ils
comprennent que tout ceci est très
anciens et que pour repenser tout ça
comme si ça venait d'arriver comme un
phénomène complètement nouveau qui nous
dépasse c'est d'une bêtise confondante
et c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu qu'ils
aient cette partie culturelle dans
interdit d'interdire pour qu'on puisse
enfin comprendre souvent de cours on
parle parce que c'est pas seulement le
manque de mémoire c'est souvent
l'ignorance christophe botti fait dire
des inepties juste il nous reste très
peu de temps je vais dire un mot de du
livre que vous venez de publier au même
moment il faut rappeler que votre parent
c'était jean luc godard et vous venez de
publier un livre alors c'est un peu
votre portrait cinématographique
quasiment puisque vous avez été acteur
également
et ça ça titulaire chant parle
parvulesco alors juste un mot sur ce
livre puisque perdu l'escaut personne ne
sait qui c'est tous les ans en 2001 ce
qu est ce que vous n'avez pas voulu
trouver d'abord jean luc godard
je me suis cherché moi même en fait
c'était moi l'objet du livre je me suis
cherché parce que vous savez c'est vrai
comme vous le rappeliez j'ai eu
vu la chance ou la matière je ne sais
pas de tourner dans la guerre des
boutres l'âge de quatre ans de faire
trois godard avant l'âge de dix ans
fabre mg et dans un ballotté par la vie
de façon un peu particulière avant de
faire un éléphant ça trompe énormément à
l'âge de 18 ans succès mondial en fin dé
vécu des choses un peu complexe et je
suis allé à la recherche d'un personnage
du un peu mythiques du cinéma français
jean parvulesco c'est quelqu'un qui
apparaît sous les traits de jean pierre
melville dans le premier film de jean
luc godard qui s'appelle à bout de
souffle
on voit un personnage chapeautait des
lunettes noires qui descend d'un avion à
ce moment là les journalistes dont fait
partie jean seberg se jettent sur lui
pour lui poser des questions magnifique
du genre qu'est ce que la vie pour vous
qu'est ce que l'amour etc
et cet homme vers lequel convergent de
journalistes se fait appeler dans le
film jean parvulesco dont jean pierre
melville joue jean parvulesco qui a
cette phrase merveilleuse mon but c'est
devenir immortel et puis mourir
et donc voilà j'ai et je veux à travers
le je me suis dit mais qui est jean
parvulesco alors il a écrit 50 lycéens
personnage invraisemblable que
d'ailleurs mon cher frédéric nous
connaissons vous et moi puisque je les
fais venir dans votre émission ce soir
ou jamais je crois que c'était en 2008
ou 2010 quelque chose comme ça pour
participer à la de nos débats et il
n'avait strictement rien dit sauf une
phrase à la fin qui est formidable mais
il faut lire le livre
je rappelle le nouvelle histoire de
l'ultra gauche le nouveau livre de
christophe bourseiller qui vient de
paraître aux éditions du saf ont fait
une pause on se retrouve juste après
avec nathalie quintane nathalie quintane
vous vous publiez à hamster à l'école la
fabrique
vous êtes professeur depuis une
quarantaine d'années et écrivain depuis
un bon quart de siècle
alors je les dis c'est un livre
extrêmement original qui se lit comme un
roman il y a un ton une vision c'est à
la fois très drôle et ça vous donne
envie envie de pleurer
mais pourquoi ce titre ah mais je peux
pas tout dévoiler dès le début moi j'ai
pensé quand je vois le livre mais avant
de le lire et que je vois ce titre je me
suis dit au fond d'être prof
c'est comme d'être un hamster dans sa
roue tourne veillez les hamsters qu'on
voit tourner indéfiniment dans une roue
mais est-ce que vous êtes consciente que
c'est l'image que ça donne avant qu
lisent le livre avant qu'on lise le
livre certes c'est une certaine image de
l'institution aussi je crois pas
simplement des individus qui la peuplent
après si on ouvre un tout petit peu
livre on s'aperçoit que le hamster c'est
une figure presque fantomatiques qui
apparaît en fait très brièvement
j'allais dire qu'il ne concerne que
l'une des voix du livre la narratrice où
le narrateur on pourrait dire peut-être
un peu l'auteur mais pas forcément ça
correspond pas forcément à moi tels que
je suis là en train de vous parler et
donc je pense qu'il faut pas le sait pas
une image qui colle exactement qui
tendrait à coller aux professeurs ou à
l'enseignant avec un grand e
c'est quelque chose qui est plus celle
des plus une idée de rendre compte d'une
forme d'étrangeté de distance par
rapport à cette institution qui est un
peu monumental
de produire un décalage alors ça
commence à la fin des années 70 quand
vous alors je dis vous c'est le
narrateur c'est la narratrice mais pour
moi c'est vous quand vous avez changé
d'école en passant du 93 au 95 vos
parents avaient déménagé et tout à coup
vous et vous qui étiez très très bonne
en maths
tout à coup vous devenez nul et là vous
vous rendez compte qu'il ya un problème
au fond c'est un problème dont on a
souvent parlé à l'école au fond selon
selon va à l'école à tel endroit ou à
telle autre
l'enseignement des pales même c'est
comme si on avait des cours aménagés en
fait oui alors l'idée c'est que le livre
en fête
passez par l'expérience sensible de
quelqu'un qui a vécu ça à 14 ans 15 ans
16 ans et j'ai essayé de faire en sorte
qu'on soit dans la peau de cette
personne qui découvre ça avec une forme
de surprise pas de qui comprend pas en
réalité
politiquement si vous voulez ce qui est
en train de se passer les bras les bras
m'en tombent aujourd'hui de tout ce que
de tout ce que je raconte dans le livre
mais ce que j'essaye de faire c'est
d'être aussi cette voie là et cette
personne là à l'époque et donc ça se
traduit par plus de perplexité
d'étonnement que de révolte ou de
compréhension d'intelligence politique
donc il n'ya pas de grandes catégories
sociologiques ou autres dans ce livre là
c'est aura de l'expérience sensible et
s'il y a des conclusions sociologique ou
politiques à en tirer c'est plutôt du
côté du lecteur que ça se passe ça
cherche pas à imposer quoi que ce soit
même si on sent bien que ce qui se passe
c'est ça c'est la différence entre un
établissement qui est plutôt occupé par
des gens des classes populaires
et puis un autre à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de distance qui va être
plutôt investis par la petite
bourgeoisie ou la bourgeoisie de
l'époque de la fin des années 70 début
des années 80 de la même manière ça va
se reproduire quand votre votre
personnage
fait une prépa et
pour dans le 95 d'abord et puis ensuite
la même prépa pour normale normale sup
mais dans un lycée parisien et elle qui
était très bonne en france seul coup se
retrouve avec des notes très très nul
alors cela dit la plupart des élèves se
trouve avec des notes très très nul mais
on voit bien que là il ya quelque chose
il ya ceux qui sont déjà programmés pour
réussir en classe c'est ceux qui sont
déjà entraînés toute leur vie en fait
ils vont payer la passé comme ça en
classe et puis d'ailleurs après ils
deviendront prof
oui c'est ce qui s'est passé en ce qui
me concerne mais la vraie bourgeoisie
parisienne que j'ai rencontré enfin une
toute petite partie que j'ai rencontré
en khâgne à l'époque
à condorcet ne devienne pas forcément
enseignants s'ils sont un peu malin il
faut ensuite d'autres grandes écoles
qu'on connaît bien sciences po l'ena et
caetera et ils ont une carrière
prestigieuse ou brillante selon leurs
yeux on va dire moi je suis resté en
seignante parce que justement j'ai raté
quelque chose
enfin j'ai j'ai raté normale sup en
l'occurrence est au fond le parcours que
j'ai eue de d'enfants des classes
moyennes à l'époque dont mes parents
étaient employés des postes venus de
province et du thé à paris de manière
très classique dans les années 60 et
aujourd'hui je suis encore enseignante
en collège si vous voulez c'est un
parcours où on ne peut pas vraiment dire
qu'il y ait eu une forme d'ascenseur
social qui met envoyé au septième ciel
si mais ce que je veux dire c'est assez
resté relativement horizontale au fond
peut-être que si j'étais resté dans le
93 sur est devenu plutôt assistante
sociale c'est ce que ce à quoi je me
destinais moi à l'époque quand j'avais
18 ans mais les jets les voilà certains
événements ont fait que ça ne s'est pas
passé tout à fait comme ça vous vous
êtes devenu prof d'abord à dunkerque
dans la campagne qu'elle quel effet ça
fait voulu raconter en détail dans l'est
mais quel effet ça fait
d'arriver à dunkerque enfin dans la
région dunkerque dans la campagne dans
un lycée est son premier poste quand on
vient justement de la banlieue
parisienne
ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
banlieue parisienne
rétrospectivement je les ai revus et
redécouvertes comme une forme de
province
c'est quelque chose que les gens qui ont
vécu enfant en banlieue ou même après ça
va mal aux mains d'or lieu c'était le 93
des pierrefitte-sur-seine et quand on
s'y balade encore aujourd'hui je faisais
ce que j'ai fait il ya pas tellement
longtemps
c'est très provincial donc j'ai
découvert une autre province mais
quelque chose s'est inversée c'est à
dire que quand j'ai fait ses classes
préparatoires ou et les études
supérieures après pour devenir prof
qu'on passe le capes
j'étais si vous voulez il y avait au
dessus de moi des gens de classe
supérieure
voilà et quand je suis arrivé dans ce
petit collège delà de la campagne
dunkerquoise j'ai découvert que j'étais
comment dire au dessus d'une certaine
manière des élèves qui étaient quand ils
rentraient chez eux s'occuper de la
sphère de travail est en fait une avec
très peu de temps très peu le loisir de
refaire les exercices comme leur
enseignant le leur suggérer j'ai
découvert un autre décalage mais en sens
inverse par rapport aux au public qui
était devant moi on s'aperçoit en vous
lisant qu'il ya une forme d'autonomie
dans l'éducation nationale les
établissements peuvent avoir leur petite
spécialité
ce premier lycée à dunkerque par exemple
fera quand et qu'on y mange très bien
il ya une cantine c'est la meilleure
cantine que vous ayez jamais vu en
depuis le temps vous êtes prof vous
n'avez jamais connu une meilleure par
exemple on peut tout à coup avoir des
initiatives
c'est un livre qui parle de la
nourriture qu'ils parlent des meubles
qui parle des vêtements qui parle des
trousses donc qu'ils abhorrent de
l'institution de manière extrêmement
dans le détail dans les objets dans les
gestes dans les sensations et la cantine
c'est quand même une part importante
d'une vie dans l'éducation nationale
une vidéo avec une vie d'étudiant donc
les initiatives à l'époque parce qu'on
est là au milieu des années 80 sont
elles peuvent être de cet ordre presque
expérimental que dans ce tout petit
collège de campagne un cuisinier parce
qu'à l'époque il y avait des cuisiniers
des chefs cuistots dans les cantines
ça a disparu depuis pouvait mettre en
place un régime diététique originale
avec des recettes prévues chaque jour et
cetera mais tout ça n'est plus possible
depuis longtemps puisque maintenant ce
sont des unités de cuisine centrale donc
si vous avez du poisson surgelé le
vendredi dentelle collèges de la région
paca à nice vous avez exactement la même
chose à marseille ou à sa une les alpes
ou assisteront vous voyez ça par exemple
ça c'est ça a beaucoup changé
vous vous raconter de la même façon que
quelqu'un un jour a décidé qu'il y
aurait des des cours d'histoire de l'art
des vrais cours d'histoire de l'art
vous allez même vous retrouver dans le
jury et puis avant ça s'arrête
comme ça on a l'impression que c'est par
la baguette du saint-esprit quelque
chose apparaît un moment qui peut être
bien ou pas bien d'ailleurs
et puis ça disparaît mais est-ce qu'à
chaque fois on comprend d'où ça vient
et pourquoi sa samba alors on raconte
c'est une rumeur mais on raconte que
l'idée de l'enseignement d'histoire des
arts au collège viendrait de carla
sarkozy
khaled voilà bien la sarkozie qui aurait
suggéré que il faudrait donner des cours
d'histoire de l'art dans les collèges je
ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais de toute
façon c'est tomber exactement comme ça
comme si d'un coup de baguette magique
quelqu'un on sait qu'ils avaient décidé
que ça que ça serait fait sauf
qu'évidemment dans les dents de ses
établissements il n'y a pas de
d'enseignants qualifiés donc l'histoire
des arts c'était pas histoire de l'art
c'est des histoires des arts devait être
réparti entre à peu près tout le monde
puisque évidemment ça ne
et les professeurs da place d'arts
plastiques ont une heure pour chaque
place n'est pas suffisant pour préparer
à ce type de deux des preuves c'était un
oral un oral en troisième donc tout le
monde était censé plus ou moins préparé
à ça sans être lui-même préparé et puis
au début c'était un peu voilà c'était un
peu de l'architecturé un peu des toiles
à un peu de musique un peu s'était
appuyé sur la fin on a fini dans les
dents les affiches publicitaires quoi
plutôt un vous vous faites passer le bac
à maman il vous réalisez que les
candidats choisissent à 80% le
commentaire de texte et vous dites que
autrefois en fin de votre temps et du
mien d'ailleurs le commentaire de texte
est plutôt choisi parce qu'ils étaient
très littéraire ce qu'il fallait être un
peu
il fallait être un peu studieux dans ce
domaine alors qu'est-ce qu'il ya
qu'est-ce qui a opéré ce revirement
pourquoi tout à coup aujourd'hui des
gens qui sont pas du tout littéraire
prennent tout ce commentaire de texte
bon c'est certainement l'une des
multiples réformes du baccalauréat qui
fait que le résumé discussions ayant
disparu puisque c'était cette épreuve là
au bac de français qui étaient prises
par les élèves qui n'étaient pas
spécialement littéraire la dissertation
étant très difficile
même à mon époque j'ai aperçu je me suis
aperçu pardon que la plupart des
candidats choisis c'est le commentaire
littéraire ce qui fait que en fait
le bac je les fais passer dans un
établissement qui est plutôt pas mal ici
dans l'endroit où j'habite
c'est celle que c'est devenu quelque
chose l'analyse du texte devenu quelque
chose d'assez techniciens ou techniciste
alors on relève voilà les champs
lexicaux où on relève les figures de
style et une sorte d'apprentissage du
répertoire de toutes les figures de
style jusqu alors d othello b hôtels
tout le houleux l'oxymore monsieur
demain et c est ce qui fait que comme
c'est centré sur une explication
vraiment voilà précise technicienne ça
manque quelquefois de recul par rapport
au sens du texte ça peut produire des
contresens alors pas toujours mais il ya
une perception de la littérature qui
tend de ce fait à être un peu biaisé
peut-être on parle de toujours des
classes difficiles alors vous vous
donner deux exemples un moment vous on
vous devez faire court cet entre deux
lycées vous devez faire cours à saumur à
une sixième qui n'a que 19 élèves on
vous dit c'est le pied 19 élèves
seulement ça va être formidable et en
fait ça va pas être formidable du tout
c'est ce qu'on appelle une classe
difficile qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que ça
fait quand on est prof comme vous et
qu'on se retrouve face à une classe
comme celle ci d'abord qu'est-ce qui les
caractérisait et quel effet ça produit
combien se rendre compte que en fait que
ce soit de cette classe ou une autre
c'est un milieu très instable un groupe
d'élèves
il peut être très sympathique et l
écoute en septembre un peu moins en
octobre leur devenir deux semaines après
sa fessée et c'est donc ça dépend
vraiment des moments de l'année ça
dépend de la dynamique de groupe ça
dépend des élèves qui les a là en plus
ou en moins
tout ça c'est aussi ce que j'essaye de
rendre de rendre compte
c'est très difficile de rendre compte
réellement de la manière concrète dont
se passe
l'enseignement dont se passe un tour en
collège et là pour cette place là en
fait j'étais remplaçante
évidemment on vous dit rien on vous
prévient pas de ce qui va se passer un
bon et
ces élèves c'est est ce qu'on appelle
une casse veto à tous avaient des
difficultés d'ordre très variés à mon
avis aussi bien personnelles familiales
sociales cos scolaire on les avait tous
mire ensemble et déjà l'idée c'était que
les profs face de la garderie en réalité
parce que dans ces circonstances là vous
ne pouvez pas suivre
je suis réellement chaque élève il
aurait fallu des groupes beaucoup plus
petit un enseignement adapté
alors peut-être que ces élèves là était
à la limite des tests puisque on
s'imagine que les tests c'est l'alpha et
l'oméga et que à partir du moment où
vous passer le test vous pouvez aller
dans une sixième classique et si vous
êtes juste en dessous vous allez dans
une classe adaptée mais on a une vision
quand même assez particulière de
l'intelligence est temps qu'elle sera
chiffré évalué cadre est comme ça ça va
donner des catastrophes de ce type là
quoi pour les enfants autant pour les
enseignants saumur c'est dans le
maine-et-loire et vous dit que le maine
et loire c'est un des coins les plus
terribles de france après la guyane
pourquoi le maine-et-loire pourquoi la
guyane et qu'est ce que c'est qu'un coin
terrible bon alors c'est un livre qui
joue aussi sur des hyperboles les
exagérations une forme d'humour
je ne suis pas allé en guyane mais c'est
tout
tout ce que ce qu'apple se ce mot là un
pour nous l'histoire le bagne etc
c'est toujours cet attentat quand on est
jeune prof dans quelle galère je vais je
vais être nommé muté en débutant alors
le maine et loire c'est un cas un peu
particulier parce que le souvenir que
j'en ai j'y suis resté deux ans je
faisais des remplacements divers et
variés
c'est d'une voix là quand on quand on
prenait la voiture dès qu'on essaye de
nous d'essayer doublé mais pas forcément
de manière intempestive
on était klaxonner etc c'était des gens
très très comment dire je me souviens
d'autres choses je m'étais dit à
l'époque que je me familiarise très bien
avec les vins et donc j'étais allé taper
à une porte pour prendre des sortes de
cours d'oenologie et c'était donc
j'avais ouvert la porte et puis avait ce
tapis rouge
cette dame au talon
très bien mise et et puis du coup
j'étais reparti ce n'était pas pour moi
les profs de gauche vous dit que c'est
une légende et vous allez même plus loin
vous dites avoir les preuves sont pas de
gauche et vous aller plus haut vous
dites ces mêmes incompatibles je sais
pas si je dis ça exactement mais le fait
est que les profs de gauche et il y en a
sans doute eu au lendemain de 68
j'ai travaillé aussi sur cette période
pour un autre livre et ce qui s'est
passé c'est que dans l'éducation
nationale au lendemain de 68 il ya eu
une forte répression et tous les
enseignants qui étaient réellement de
gauche à qui avaient été nourris par
l'expérience 68
en fait on était révoqué ou suspendu
avec ou sans traitement y compris
d'ailleurs pour les mouvements lycéens
il ya eu un mouvement lycéen très fort
les comités d'action lycéens qui ont
perduré jusqu'en 72 73 et en 73 ya eu un
coup d'arrêt c'est à dire que dès qu'il
y avait des mouvements un peu trop fort
dans un lycée le la direction pouvait
aller jusqu'à virer l'ensemble d'une
classe d'une année sur l'autre et on
pouvait passer en conseil de discipline
pour pas grand chose donc le nettoyage
en réalité a été fait dans l'institution
et tous les enseignants qui réellement
comptait mettre en place une politique
de pédagogie alternative cohérente et
pas simplement sur certains détails si
vous voulez accessoires ou pas cela on
les a plus trop vu ou alors on va dire
est qu'ils sont plus ou moins rentrés
dans le rang où ils se sont fait très
discret donc ce qui s'est passé c'est
que est resté dans l'institution une
population d'enseignants qui en fait
très représentative de je crois de la
population dans son ensemble avec une
petite partie à l'extrême droite une
toute petite partie vraiment la gauche
ou à gauche tout court pour moi c'est la
même chose
et puis au milieu des gens bord en gros
je caricature peut être un mais qui
votent socialistes qui sont de droite
vous raconter quelque chose dont j'avais
toujours eu l'intuition quand j'étais
élève
même si je n'étais pas dans une classe
problématique
on dira mais c'est le plaisir qui peut y
avoir pour le professeur à nous faire
des dictées et en fait vous raconter
bien quel point c'est reposant pour vous
de faire une dictée et et c'est reposant
aussi de la corriger
oui alors c'est un passage la hausse y
aura de l'enseignement parce qu'on a en
france en particulier tout une espèce de
vision fantasmagorique de l'orthographe
j'ai pas y revenir et je n'y reviens pas
d'ailleurs dans le livre c'est pas ça
qui m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse c'est
ça c'est le ce que cet exercice là
particulier produit dans la classe 1
c'est à dire le silence total évidemment
le rêve de n'importe quel parent ou de
n'importe quel enseignant puisque les
élèves sont sont très concentrés pour
pouvoir suivre la dictée donc vous avez
ainsi une paix royale vous en profiter
un pendant dix minutes un quart d'heure
le temps que ça dure et puis au niveau
des corrections de copies
j'en parle aussi évidemment c'est le
sait le mieux c'est une correction très
automatique car en fait on peut très
bien écouter la radio en même temps
puisque les les fautes très vite sont
souvent les mêmes bons donc c'est un
paquet de copies très vite corrigé
et puis tout le monde est content au
fond qui irait contester ou ou dire
quelque chose sur le fait que vous
faites des dictées vous pouvez très bien
en faire une par jour personne ne
viendra vu le statut de l'orthographe en
france personne ne viendra vous
contester ce fait là tandis que si vous
essayez de deux d'expliquer un texte je
ne sais pas au hasard d'antonin artaud
de jules vallès certains passages là ça
sera peut être autre chose et de même la
notation personne personne ne viendra
contester la note elle est objective
il n'y a pas de subjectivité du tout
derrière la correction mais vous vous
demandez aussi ce que ça prouve au fond
la dictée parce que on a érigé la dictée
nous pour nous c'est en france d'une
institution je me souviens des dictée de
bernard pivot à la télé en prime time et
il y avait plein de gens qui regardaient
il regardait les autres faire une dictée
s'est quand même fait sinon qu'est-ce
que ça prouve les dictées après tout
rien n'indique t c'est bon d'avoir ça
pour rien puisque j'ai de dax et leurs
amis qu'ils ont fait
les études supérieures et qui sont
dyslexiques et inversement
je ne pense pas que les la plupart des
personnes qui ne font aucune faute
d'orthographe soit 6 brillantissime que
sa part ailleurs donc il ya vraiment une
uniforme bien à faire la séparation
entre une forme d'intelligence sensible
et le fait d'appliquer simplement de
parvenir à appliquer une règle
d'orthographe
or on a tendance à confondre les deux
par exemple sur les on sait bien que sur
les réseaux de rencontre il ya un tri
par l'orthographe sur les réseaux
sociaux sociaux il ya un tri par
l'orthographe et c'est une monumentale
erreur
évidemment l'enseignement l'avantagent
de l'enseignement c'est que c'est l'oral
c'est le fait qu'on se parle c'est le
fait qu'on se voit c'est le fait qu'on
se sente une certaine manière c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est quelque chose
de physique
c'est une pratique physique à une
physique de l'enseignement de
l'enseignant et des élèves et le
télétravail qu'on a pu expérimenter la
avec le confinement ne marche pas à
l'école
en tout cas ne marche pas au collège
dans la plupart des cas à 90% pour en
avoir fait l'expérience
je peux vous le dire donc je ne sais
plus quel était votre question c'était
sur l'orthographe c'est ça oui c'est sa
manière à lui une dictée au fond ça ne
trouve rien ça ne prouve rien ça ne
prouve rien mais c'est on va dire
confortable et pratique
alors vous ne vous expliquer très bien
que souvent vous demande ce serait quoi
l'école idéale l'école que vous
préconisez auriez vous dites qu'au fond
vous ne savez pas mais revault je vous
demandais vous poser une question de
savoir ce que c'est que le boulot d'un
prof
alors après y avoir beaucoup réfléchi
c'est quoi pour vous le boulot d'un prof
qui est encore le vôtre aujourd'hui 1
c'est en ce moment je n'ai je n'établis
aucune hypothèse je fais pas de plans
sur la comète
en ce moment c'est d'être là et c'est de
rassurer mais je crois que c'était déjà
le cas auparavant simplement ça s'est
accentué évidemment depuis un an
pour pouvoir travailler avec les élèves
pour qu'ils puissent commencer à
travailler
il faut qu'ils soient rassurés parce que
les élèves que j'ai et que j'ai eu et
que j'ai particulièrement en ce moment
sont sous pression ils le disent de
manière très claire
l'orientation locaux vides les
difficultés diverses sont des élèves qui
sont très souvent stressés donc le rôle
de l'enseignant c'est d'être à côté
d'eux avec eux est de dire ça va aller
on commence comme ça et puis une fois
qu'ils ont bien compris que ça va aller
là on va pouvoir commencer à travailler
et il boulot des élèves alors souffrit
quoi le boulot des élèves ça serait de
trouver le moyen de ne pas s'ennuyer
est-ce qu'ils fabulent relève que vous
êtes écrivain c'est variable je
n'enseigne pas sous même nom après ça
s'est su évidemment depuis le temps mais
je pourrais vous dire c'est intéressant
pour ceux qui écrivent justement qui
veulent écrire pour les autres aussi bon
parce que voilà il ya peut-être des
choses qui passent par là le fait que je
les fasse écrire assez souvent que
j'essaye de 2 voilà de leur donner des
tuyaux si tout simplement je leur donne
des tuyaux d'écrivains quelque chose des
petits trucs mais les gens quand ils
sont adultes se souviennent
beaucoup d'entre eux tout cas se
souviennent d'un prof qui les a marqués
qui parfois leur a donné la vocation
faire quelque chose est ce que l inverse
on se souvient de certains élèves
est ce qu'il ya des élèves qui vous ont
marqué et qui parfois vous ont donné la
vocation de faire quelque chose bien sûr
de toute façon si je suis resté dans
l'enseignement c'est c'est pour eux
c'est pour eux et et pour cette raison
parce que papa
certains élèves particulièrement
étonnant au brillant ou pas brillant du
tout d'ailleurs qu'importe des fortes
personnalités 1 des personnalités
singulières oui bien sûr j'ai ses
souvenirs là des fois des souvenirs très
anciens maintenant de ces élèves là mais
en fait ce qui fait que j'y suis encore
et que j'y reste
c'est vraiment le groupe classe c'est
vraiment tous ces élèves là et au
collège il ya tout le monde s'est pas
encore tout à fait trier comme on dit un
c'est à dire qu'il ya des élèves qui
arrivent très très bien on a envie de
leur dire mais vas-y écrit maintenant et
puis je te filerai une adresse de
d'éditeurs et on va négocier ça on va
voir ça c'est possible évidemment y
compris à 14 ans 15 ans ou même avant
et puis on a d'autres voilà qui sont un
peu perdus vous avez tout cela est
totalement
voilà toute la masse des autres et donc
quand j'y vais c'est pour les retrouver
tous ça c'est important
j'ai trouvé ce livre formidable je les
dis il ya un vrai ton qui est très
original est-ce que vous même quand vous
étiez au collège on vous a dit
toi tu as peut-être du talent il faudra
peut-être que tu écrives jour je me
souviens pas vraiment qu'on ait dit ça
directement qua non on a plutôt dit on
what est bonne en france et vas-y
continue fait des études de lettres pour
un prof c'était parce que vous savez
voilà voilà c'est ça en fait il ya une
espèce de c'est ça aussi la roue la roue
du hamster c'est que en patient le le
concours enfin passions de bach en
passant le k perse et puis après
beaucoup plus tard en passant là greg je
me suis aperçu que ça c'est que en face
de vous vous avez un jury qui vous
reconnaît comme l'un des siens futurs
potentiels ou qui ne vous reconnaît pas
comme l'un des siens et à partir du
moment où ils vous reconnaît comme l'un
des siens là il vous file le truc il fit
le fil le concours j'ai compris ça
beaucoup plus précisément quand j'ai
passé la grecque parce que j'avais plus
18 ans j'avais plus 20 ans hamster à
l'école c'est le nouveau livre de
nathalie quintane qui vient de paraître
à la fabrique merci d'attali merci tous
les deux d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]